Sara wanted to figure out if she did
better on tests by studying two more
hours or by sleeping two more hours she
chartered she charted her results for
ten different tests so this is when she
studied two more hours and this is when
she slept two more hours and they asked
us based on the data should set should
Sara study more or sleep more the night
before a test and so this isn't a huge
sample of data so we won't talk about
things like statistical significance and
all of that but just based on the
information we have let's see if we can
have any draw any at least initial
conclusions so the first thing that we
might want to do is let's just compare
studying studying two hours more or
sleeping two hours more and let's let's
calculate let's calculate some
statistics over here so let's let's
think about her let's think about her
mean test score when she's studying
versus when she studies two more hours
versus when she sleeps two more hours so
let's think about the mean so the mean
here we're going to add up all of these
and then divide by five let me get a
calculator out just for do these a
little bit quicker so the mean time when
she's studying is going to be 93 plus 72
plus 78 plus 82 plus 82 + 79 plus 79 and
then divide by five there's five data
points here so her mean score when she
studies two hours more is 80 point eight
so this is 80 point eight and what is
the mean score on her exams when she
sleeps two hours more when she sleeps
two hours more so 85 plus 89 plus 81
plus 95 plus 86 divided by five is
eighty seven point two eighty seven
point two so just looking at that and
she has a higher average higher mean
test score when she sleeps two hours
more
maybe that's because sleep is more
important or maybe it's just she felt
more confident going into those exam so
it felt like she doesn't need to study
much
but that's at least a data point that's
why this isn't really a good good
research
whenever the experimental subject is the
ones performing the the actual study
they kind of know what's going to happen
maybe they know that they have to they
can they don't have to study as much for
the exams that are easy or who knows
what they are but let's just actually
calculate the whole purpose of this is
to actually just calculate the different
mean II mean median mode and all the
rest so let's just calculate now the
median let's calculate the median so to
calculate the median you want to put all
of these in order and then pick out the
middle so if you want to put it in order
when she's studying I'll just write it
over here you have the lowest is 72 then
you have then after that you the next
lowest is 78 78 the next lowest is 79 79
the next lowest is 82 82 and then you
have 93 93 so the median when she
studies two more hours is 79 and the
median when she sleeps two more hours
let's see so I'll put these in order the
lowest here is 81 81 then we have 85 85
then you have 86 86 then you have 89 89
and then you have 95 so the median here
is going to be 86 86 so once again this
measure of central tendency also says
that it looks like she does better on
exams when she sleeps two more hours
then when she studies to Mars once again
to me that doesn't conclusively say that
she should study more or sleep more that
just says that what for exams where she
happens to sleep more she happens to do
better but it might go to it might be
the exams that she's more confident on
she's willing to study less and then
sleep more or it might be that sleeping
is actually what's helping her on the
exam so we don't know but at least we
know that the median and the mean is
higher when she sleeps more now let's
think about the mode what's the most
common so the mode so the mode is the
most frequent result and when she's
studying there is no single most
frequent result if any of these
seventy-eight twice then that would have
been the mode but they're all of these
scores are unique so there is no there
is no mode there is no mode for the
studying and the same thing is true for
the sleeping all of these are unique if
one of these showed up with a higher
frequency than the others then that
would be the mode but there is nothing
that shows up more frequently than
everything else now let's think about
the range and this essentially will tell
us how spread apart are these values
what's the difference between the
highest and the lowest value so when the
studying the highest value is 93 lowest
value is 22 the range sorry this is not
22 this 72 right all right 70 this is a
72 highest value is 93 lowest value is
72 and so the range the range in this
situation is 93 minus 72 which is equal
to 21 which is equal to 21 and then the
range over here the range when she
sleeps more is 95 minus 81 which is
equal to 14 so this doesn't tell us
anything about really the central
tendency but it does say that her scores
when she sleeps more tend to be less
spread around so 1 they tend to be
generally higher when we look at some of
their central tendency measures and they
also seem to be less spread about when
she studies more her her average scores
or her median scores tend to be a little
bit lower and the range theirs looks
like there's more variety in how well
she actually does there's a bigger
difference between her high score and
her lowest score and then finally let's
try to do the mid range so the mid range
is just the average of her highest and
lowest scores
then green mid range and it's another
measure kind of central tendency
so the mid range average of highest and
lowest scores so mid range mid range is
going to be 93 plus 72 divided by 2 so
this is what 165 165 over 2 which is
eighty two point five eighty two point
five at least in this example wasn't too
far away from the mean or the median and
then the mid range when she sleeps more
is going to be
so the mid-range is going to be 95 plus
81 95 plus 81 over 2 so this is equal to
176 over 2 and that is what that is 88
that is is that right yep 80 times 2 is
160 then you have another 16 so that is
88 88 so I don't know if you could based
on this data
tell Sarah that she could definitely
study more sleep more I guess they're
probably saying oh once you look at this
it looks like she does better when she's
when she sleeps more but that by itself
you don't know if she's sleeping more if
the sleep is causing so you don't know
if the sleep is causing her to do better
so that's one theory and I think that's
what the writer of this question was
thinking that some you know that this is
enough to make a conclusion but you also
don't know maybe the maybe she the
subjects that she knows better she's
willing to study less she's willing to
study less and sleep more so you
actually don't know which way it goes is
a is is or is because you have an easy
exam the next night you're willing to
sleep more and that's why we get these
results or maybe it is really true that
the sleeping more actually makes someone
perform better even when the exams are
the same level of difficulty